Es ist wichtig
, die Wahrheit zu sagen, es ist wichtig, ein guter
Mensch zu sein
,
und es ist für viele Menschen einfacher,
wenn Sie in diesem Land Muslim sind. Sie
müssen sich keine Sorgen machen, wenn der Präsident
Sie hier nicht haben will,
wenn Sie ein Einwanderer sind  Sie müssen sich keine
Sorgen machen, ob der Präsident
glücklicher darüber sein wird, dass
Babys weggenommen werden oder
Träumer ohne Grund zurückschicken,
es ist eine Rechtfertigung für viele Menschen
, die wirklich gelitten haben.
Sie wissen, ich kann nicht atmen, das wissen Sie
war nicht nur George
Floyd, viele Leute hatten das Gefühl,
sie könnten jeden Tag nicht atmen,
wenn Sie aufwachen und
diese Tweets bekommen und Sie wissen es einfach nicht
und Sie gehen in den Laden und zu den Leuten
die
Angst hatten, ihren Rassismus zu zeigen, werden immer
fieser und fieser zu dir und du machst dir
Sorgen um deine Kinder
und du machst dir Sorgen um deine Schwester
und kann sie einfach zu Walmart gehen
und wieder in ihr Auto steigen, ohne dass
jemand etwas zu ihr sagt  sie
und und du hast so viel von deinem li ausgegeben  fe
Energie
versucht nur, es zusammenzuhalten, und das
ist eine große Sache
für uns, nur um in der Lage zu sein, etwas Frieden zu finden
und
und und eine Chance für einen Reset zu haben, und
und der Charakter des Landes ist wichtig,
und und und und es ist wichtig, ein guter Mann zu sein
Weißt du, ich möchte nur, dass meine Söhne sich
das ansehen.
Weißt du, es ist einfach, es auf die billige
Art und Weise zu machen und
und und und mit Sachen davonzukommen, aber es
kommt zurück,
es kommt zurück, und es ist ein guter Tag
dafür  Land, es tut mir leid für die
Leute, die verloren haben,
äh, für sie ist es kein guter Tag, aber für
eine ganze Menge Leute ist es ein guter Tag
präsident trump da geht der champions
b